- These ships show port calls
at ukraine's black sea ports
in the days before russia
invaded the country.
Here's how that compares
to the days after the
fighting broke out six months
after the war started
under the black sea grain
initiative, and then
again this summer after the
black sea grain deal fell apart.
They show how moscow's economic war
against ukraine is playing out
in the black sea, causing
key Ukrainian exports
to plunge, something russia has benefited
from as its exports are
reaching record highs.
So how has russia sought
to control shipping
to and from ukraine?
And what are kyiv and its allies trying
to do to counter that blockade?
Before the war, ukraine's
black sea ports exported 95%
of the country's wheat,
corn, and sunflower oil.
Ukraine's agricultural products account
for 41% of the country's total exports,
meaning they are major
drivers of ukraine's economy.
Wanting to choke ukraine off financially,
russia has taken aim
at these ports since the invasion began.
It's done this in a
number of different ways.
It's tried to capture
some strategic port cities
and it's bombarded others with missiles.
It's also destroyed infrastructure
used to export grain
and moved warships into
shipping corridors.
Now, there has been a caveat.
Last July in turkey, moscow
under diplomatic pressure agreed
to a UN broker deal known as
the black sea grain initiative,
that paved the way for
ukrainian food products
and only food products to
flow from these three ports.
You can see that port calls picked up
but they never fully recovered
to those pre-war levels
and russia was accused
of slowing down shipping
by holding up inspections.
Then this summer, shipping
came to a standstill once again
after russia withdrew from
that black sea grain deal
and threatened all commercial
ships heading toward ukraine.
(speaking foreign language)
- So how are kyiv and its allies racing
to keep ukraine's economy
and its critical food products plugged
into the rest of the world?
Early in the war,
the European Union established
these solidarity lanes
to move products in and out
of the country via road,
rail, and inland waterways.
Over much of the past year,
those overland routes handled
about 24% of ukraine's grain exports,
while the black sea ports handled 50%.
Ports over here on the Danube River
handled the remaining 26%.
Now following the collapse
of that grain deal,
the US is leading an
effort to increase capacity
here where grain is shipped
down the Danube River
and through romania's
ports on the black sea.
Even though this route is slower
and more expensive than using
ukraine's black sea ports,
it's considered to be safer
since it lies under the nato umbrella.
Ships would travel
through the waters of
romania, bulgaria, and turkey.
Those countries are part
of nato whose 31 members
consider an attack
on one to be an attack on all.
Now, the UN and turkey are
still trying to get russia back
into that grain deal, but
that might not happen.
So ukraine is also working
to open a shipping corridor
in the black sea, that would allow ships
to hug ukraine's coast before sailing
by those nato countries.
That could help Ukrainian
farmers earn more money.
But ukraine's ability to
resume exports this way depends
on whether ships can get insurance and
whether captains are
willing to take the risk
because russia isn't
guaranteeing them safe passage.
The true test for ukraine
and its allies will come
in September and October
when the country's massive
harvests are brought in.
But some ukrainian
farmers have already given
up on planting their crops
since the market and
supply chain are broken
and there are no signs of
the war ending anytime soon.
Now, as russia threatens these new routes,
the US says it's considering
all possible options
including military solutions
to protect the ships
heading to these ports.
And analysts say the threat
of a broader war spilling
into the black sea is higher
than at any point since
the conflict began.
(warm music)